[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex mullering and I'm excited
to have you here for this uh this little
lesson so uh for those especially those
living in the United States we have the
Thanksgiving holiday coming up and one
of the things that I think whether
you're in the states or not that we can
all agree on is that good food means a
good time and people eat food in
different ways right so for me uh
Thanksgiving a lot of people would eat
their food with a fork
but I think you should eat your meals
with a skewer and after tonight maybe
you'll see why skewer is the theme of
our lesson and I want to start out with
a really famous game called the skewer
lure
so this game was played in 1864 and it
goes something like this
E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop C4
we've seen it a million times but we
have an Italian game
Knight to F6 attacking the pawn on e4
but rather than defend it white
immediately plays D4 vying for control
in the center
black takes and castles again inviting
black to take this Pawn
but there are some dangers for instance
if you take now there are some dangerous
pins on the e-file
so black decided in this game to instead
just simply Play Bishop to E7
and white recaptured the pawn Knight
takes D4 Queen takes D4 and we have
basically an even game maybe white still
with the opening advantage
black continued with Pawn to D6
excuse me hoping to develop the light
squared Bishop somewhere most likely
and maybe also to prevent E5 from coming
and white decides they want to keep up
the pressure
and so white plays Pawn to F4
maybe a little bit risky you know
exposing your king generally when you're
beginning a game you want to leave your
king pretty well guarded with the pawns
but white is deciding that their pieces
are more active their control of the
center is much better and so they are
ready to push forward
black here plays an unusual move perhaps
better would have been to just Castle
kingside
um but here black plays the move B6
looking to I guess develop the bishop
onto this diagonal which is not a bad
idea but it is a little weakening now
with both D6 and V6 you can see all of
these light squares are now just kind of
a little exposed and white might be able
to find a way to take advantage of it
and white just decides to continue
immediately with Pawn to E5
following up with the plan from before
F4 E5
black in this position probably should
have taken the pawn D take C5 and we
might have seen something like Queen
takes King takes and continuing and it
would have been an interesting game
but instead
black noticed something really funny and
this also might be a secondary reason
for this idea of pushing the pawn to B6
is now after uh pushing the pawn to D5
we're opening up space for this bishop
to jump in and pin
Our Queen to our King
now white doesn't give black a chance to
do that white plays Bishop to B5 check
so you don't have time for this move
Bishop to D7
and most people in this position would
probably play a move like Bishop takes
and then maybe you know Bishop to E3
some people might just drop the queen
back to defend there are some different
ideas that could happen here but white
plays the crazy move Pawn takes F6
allowing Bishop to C5 pinning Our Queen
to the king
why on Earth would white do this well
they didn't miss this idea they actually
saw a little bit farther and realized
that they can allow the queen to be
pinned to the king if they continue with
Rook E1 check
okay well it's a little awkward
um
perhaps something could come back to
block but then this Pawn is here
that looks a little scary if the bishop
comes back to block then we lose the pin
and you don't want to block with the
queen
um and you can't block with the bishop
on D7 because it's pinned
so simply King to f8 and now really
beautiful continuation Pawn takes G7
defended by the Queen the only move is
to play King to G8 and pawn takes Rook
check mate as a promotion to a queen
even though the queen is pinned it still
defends the king prevents the king from
taking and so we have a really beautiful
game I have one problem with it though
it's misnamed this game I said was
called the skewer lure
and white does Trick uh black into
playing this move Bishop to C5 but this
is not a skewer this is a pin
and tonight we're going to learn the
difference so a skewer unlike a well
let's start with a pin I've talked about
these before
um but a pin is anytime you have one
piece that is attacking in a straight
line and hits two pieces of your
opponents one of them is less important
and that's the one in front and the one
in behind is more important so in this
case the queen cannot move off of this
diagonal or else the king would be hit
this is a pin
a skewer is actually the exact opposite
or the inverse where you hit the more
important piece in front and it has to
get out of the way so that you can take
the weaker piece in the back let me show
an example of this I'll show two
this is a very simple position to
illustrate what's going on here but in
this position it's white to move if
white played the move Rook to A6 this
would be a pin our Bishop is defending
the Rook so we are going to be safe in
this move and the blacks Queen cannot
move off of this uh rank the sixth rank
because then the king would fall the
king is more important
if white instead played the move Rook to
H6 this would be a skewer
because now the king is more important
and it has to get out of the way meaning
the queen is going to be hit by The Rook
both of these are really important
tactical ideas to know but they are
different here's one more example to
show the difference here
in this position let me put it to the
audience
white to move and see if you can find
the best move for white and why so take
a little bit of time if you are in the
chat please feel free to comment your
ideas if you're in person you have an
idea raise your hand and I will call on
you if I see you and if you're watching
this later on YouTube as always feel
free to pause the video try and find the
best move take your time with it there's
no rush
okay anyone have any idea what should
white do to play in this position for an
advantage
uh Bishop B5 looks very good but there's
actually a bit of a problem so this is a
pin uh if we play Bishop to B5 we pin
the Knight to the queen
but you see the issue with this move
what are we overlooking yeah do you have
an idea
it's okay if you're not sure
uh Bishop
oh so Bishop G4 will it would have been
another idea
um there is a slight problem there too
but that's probably better than Bishop
B5
the first thing we have to do in this
position though is realize that our
Knight is attacked twice
so if we play Bishop to B5 unfortunately
black can actually play Queen takes D4
and now we're in trouble because our
Queen is not safe if we take the Knight
we lose our Queen
but if we take the queen then the Knight
takes back and we have given up
some material here we've given up this
night
so Bishop B5 looks really good but we
can't do it right away we have to kind
of interject and change the position
slightly
yeah go ahead
so Bishop G4 also looks very good I
think this move is better
um
because you are now hitting the queen
directly although once again I am a
little worried if they take our Knight
it might get a little complicated I can
imagine black takes our Knight
we trade Queens
we take their rook and they take our
Bishop so we're going to give we're
going to trade Queens but we're going to
give up our Knight and our Bishop for
the rook and generally when we think of
the pieces and chests we think of them
in terms of like points so I would say a
knight and a bishop are both three
points together that'd be six the work
is only five so it's pretty close
but I would prefer to keep a knight and
a bishop instead of getting a rook
so not a bad idea
anyone have any other guesses in this
position
so that's okay
okay Knight takes C6
um and then what's your idea from there
yeah that looks pretty good if Queen
takes
yeah that should work either way so
first we're going to take this Knight
and then uh black has a choice
they can take with the Rook or with the
queen but either way they run into
problems
if they take with the Rook we have two
options now we can choose to play Bishop
to B5 because our Knight's not in danger
anymore so this would be a pin
but we can also Play Bishop to F3 and
this would be a skewer although in this
case it's kind of a balanced skewer the
two things that we're hitting in a row
are both the same it just works out for
us because they're both better than this
bishop so whichever one we get it's fine
um so you could do that or you could
play Bishop to B5 to pin
and if they take with the queen
then Bishop to F3 now is just the
traditional skewer we attack the queen
which is more important it has to move
out of the way and perhaps we they take
the pawn
and when the dust settles this Rook Has
Fallen
so uh that's again the the difference
between a pin and a skewer both are very
similar ideas we're going to use one of
our pieces to attack in a straight line
uh two of our opponent's pieces it's
just whichever one is more important
whether it's the first one or the one
behind that's what determines it so this
would be a pin the less important piece
is in front and so this piece can't move
or else they lose this one
whereas this would be a skewer they want
to move the more important piece because
they don't want it to get hit but then
something is Left Behind
okay let's take a look at a few more
kind of basic examples and then I want
to show a game so first of all we have
this position
and it's White's turn to move and try
and find the best move
so keeping in mind what we're talking
about and especially you know we're
looking for skewers so the pattern
recognition is kind of at play now we
just have to find how can we make it
happen in the best way
yes
[Music]
yeah really good so Bishop to H4 in this
position we hit the black queen and the
Black Knight and the problem is uh this
queen can't move anywhere that defends
the Knight
so black would love to play a move like
Queen to E6 but unfortunately our Bishop
protects that square oh yes
uh oh G5 G5 does not work here in some
cases it might but because our Knight
also covers the square we can just take
that pawn and they still can't take our
Bishop
so not a bad idea sometimes you could
try and interpose the attack but in this
case G this doesn't actually change
anything the queen still has to move and
wherever it moves
this Knight will fall
all right here's another uh fairly basic
example one more step complicated from
the last time
so kind of weirdly imbalanced position
here where both sides have three pawns
both sides have a knight and a bishop
but black has two Rooks and white has
the queen which is a fairly balanced
game but just depends on Whose pieces
are more active
in this case it is black to move
does anyone see the best continuation
for black
go ahead
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so you've come up with most of the ideas
so it's actually slightly different in
the first one so the you are correct if
we take on F3
um then white has two options they can
either take back with the king or the
bishop they can't really take with the
bishop though because not a skewer the
bishop is pinned to the queen if the
bishop were to move the queen which is
more important would get taken so they
don't want to do this
but unfortunately taking with the King
allows as you said Bishop to D5
skewering the king and the bishop and in
this case even though the king can move
somewhere to defend the bishop that's
probably not a good idea because then
we're going to end up being able to
trade our Rook for the queen
well our rook and our Bishop but we'll
be left with a rook so this would be
very very good for us
and again we found our skewer first by
trading these pieces so a nice forcing
move
and then after white recaptures we
attack the more important King force it
to move and win this bishop
okay now that you have the basic idea of
what a skewer is I want to look at a
quick game and then we're going to look
at a bunch of examples from other Grand
Master games this is a pretty short game
between Bobby Fischer and Stefan's in
1957 where Fisher finds a really really
nice idea that involves a skewer
um okay
so Fisher had white and he played E4 C5
so we have a Sicilian
and some fairly normal moves
taking in the center
and black has achieved the idea of the
Sicilian of trading this side Pawn for
one of White Center pawns but white does
have more Center space
Knight to F6 attacking E4 and Knight to
C3 defending
G6 opening up this diagonal for the
bishop
Bishop E3 Knight to C6
F3 giving a little more support to the
center perhaps opening up a home for
this bishop on F2 Maybe
Bishop to G7 Queen to D2 castles Bishop
to C4 developing A6 and queen side
castles both sides have almost all their
pieces developed black has yet to
develop this minor Bishop but they're
both castled and the game is fairly
afoot
Queen to C7
um
and Bishop to B3 this move is kind of
anticipating two things so Fisher plays
Bishop to B3 because he's worried one
that this move B5 is going to force that
and also now that the queen is on C7 if
this Knight is to move
then the queen will attack the bishop so
he doesn't want to allow that Discovery
he just drops the bishop back and black
plays a very normal looking move
unfortunately it has a problem
Pawn to B5 looking to expand on the
queen side perhaps to develop this
bishop to B7
but here white has a fantastic fantastic
idea I'm not going to make you try and
find it but if you want to feel free to
take a quick look if you're online
always feel free to pause but see if you
can find the best idea for white but if
you can't find it don't worry too much
does anyone have a guess
what might you play if you were white in
this position
and while you're thinking about that uh
yes so I like Ben feingold's advice of
avoiding playing F3 or F6 in most cases
but yeah at the highest level they know
exactly when to break the rules so it
does leave you a bit weak on this
diagonal but as long as you can avoid
those problems you should be okay still
better safe than sorry do you have an
idea for this position
there there actually isn't any weakness
along the H4 top you want E1 diagonal
because there's nothing to attack yes so
that's why F3 was okay in this position
because
um this is actually a little earlier so
back when F3 happened the main things
you want to look out for are these
pieces that can attack on this diagonal
and since there's a lot of kind of just
junk in the way it's going to be a hard
time for black to open up the position
enough to make this attack worthwhile
whereas white only has to play two moves
to get their King out of danger so
that's a really good point something is
only a weakness if your opponent has a
means of attacking it
okay back to the position in question
the move here is actually not that hard
to find but it's the reason that's tough
Bobby Fischer decides to trade Knights
on C6 because now since B5 has been
played
uh instead of being able to take back
with the pawn if this was captured so in
this position if we decide to take this
Knight then simply the pawn captures now
the queen has to take
which means that the queen is lined up
with The Rook
and so we would love to play this move
Bishop to D5 but there's a problem
they'll just take it with the Knight so
how does Bobby mitigate that problem he
finds the really stunning move Knight to
D5
so simple so elegant and now black has
two problems if you take the Knight then
we get the skewer attacking the queen
and then the Rook through it
if you don't take the Knight
then we go Knight to E7 check and Fork
the queen and the Rook and if you don't
really allow either of those which is
what happens in the game so again
instead of Knight takes D5 this would
allow a beautiful skewer of the queen
and Rook
um and so in the game the move that
Stevens played was King to h8
allowing Knight takes E7 but just
getting out of this Fork so he's gonna
admit he's losing a pawn but that's not
enough for Bobby Bobby actually plays
Knight takes F6
because now if you take back the Knight
the skewer Still Remains and Bobby will
pick up the Rook maybe for the bishop
maybe for free
which is why in the game instead of
taking back the night E6 was played
stopping the Bishop from calling to D5
but now after a few more moves of some
trickery
pinning this bishop to The Rook
and then exchanging
Bobby pulled his Knight back and when
the dust has settled he is just up a
clean minor piece very very nice from
Fisher here
so that's the power really available to
us when you can see some of these
tactical ideas and especially of skewers
just having that lingering threat of
playing Bishop to D5 was so problematic
for black that they actually had to lose
a full piece
let's look now at a few other positions
from a bunch of Master games and see if
we can find the best one so in this
position
this was from Wolfgang unzeker this is
uh versus Mikhail tal you might have
heard of some of those players both very
famous this happened in Milan in 1975
and in this position it is white to move
so unzicker and find the winning idea
the material is totally in White's favor
so white should be winning anyway but
this is a very simple and clean way to
do it does anyone have an idea for white
here
someone in the chat here toll I believe
is your name has a suggestion of white
taking the bishop so white plays Queen
takes Bishop
and now after King takes the only move I
mean you can move the king out of the
way but then you're just giving up the
bishop
after King takes Bishop to F4 and we
pick the queen back up we just happened
to gain a bishop in the process so again
to look at that ahead of time we are
going to win both trade the Queens but
win this bishop we get rid of the bishop
and now notice that this King because
it's on the diagonal has no space to
move that is able to defend the queen so
he's not going to be able to win this
bishop something like this we simply
capture
all right next example here
this is from uh and I'm going to
mispronounce a lot of these names so I
do apologize but uh venier versus
timoshenko in 1998 and this time it is
black to move and find the best move
again now we're looking for skewers so
uh you're trying to line up some of your
opponent's pieces where a really
important one is in the front and a less
important one is behind and find a way
to take advantage of it
yes
so I found that if you sacrifice the
bishop on F3 and instead of a skewer on
G5 but the only problem with that is
that there's a Pawn on C4 so you are
very very close you have a lot of the
right ideas think a little farther so
Bishop takes F3 King takes
we can't play Queen to D5 which would
skewer the king in The Rook because of
this Pawn but is there any other way we
can skew her
yes so takes
and queen to C6 presumably we could also
play Queen to B7 but as long as we go to
one of these squares we can't go to D5
but we can go here and now again white
has nothing they can do to pick up the
Rook they can't block with any of their
pieces so we will eat up the rook and
toll again well well found in the chat
all right this one these next were
actually a little more recent so this
one is from a game between Hikaru
Nakamura and uh
Stephen Muhammad in 2004
and it is white to move and find a
really nice continuation here
oh I'm sorry uh it is not light to move
in this position it was black to move
and black played Rook to B8 attacking
our Pawn now it is white to move
oh yes
okay what's your continuation after King
takes
very good so here Rook takes D6 and Ted
Bradley in the chat well found as well
really nice stunning Material Exchange
sacrifice but we're gonna get it back
because now Bishop to F4 we line up the
king and the Rook
well well done uh the King again has
nowhere to go to save The Rook
and white is up a full piece
uh this one is actually kind of fun so
in this position uh black uh let's see
black played Bishop D6 and it's white to
move here uh this was between
viswanathon and non and uh vasely even
Chuck in uh 2005 so again some very very
strong players
and uh Anand with white went on to win
this game but he did it in a way that
was a little more complicated there's
actually a very simple way to win this
game quite easily
see if you can find a winning idea yeah
go ahead
okay
[Music]
yeah so
um this is very close to what happened
in the actual game so Rook to A7 is the
move Anon decided to play and this is
winning so this is a winning idea after
King to B6 he played Rook E7 with this
nice idea of it now uh if you he's
trying to simplify this material even
though it's a sacrifice Bishop takes
Queen takes uh
trading Queens with the idea that now
his Pawn is going to become a queen and
unfortunately even trick is just not
quite fast enough to make one of his
pawns help out white is just in time
but there is an even better move
this move also is winning so your move
is fine but the best and simplest move
here is found in the chat by Charles J
thanks for commenting
and it's actually just playing
immediately Queen takes F7 after Bishop
D6 attacking the queen immediately
sacking because now after Queen takes we
still have Rook A7 and this time it is a
skewer we force the queen of tree the
trade of Queens even earlier
and now this Pawn is going to promote
very very soon and it's white or sorry
black will probably be able to hold it
off with the King and Bishop but not
hold off everything
all right this is our next position this
is a very old game a blindfold simul
from 1868 between someone named Magnus
not the one we know and a player named
Emil shalop
it is
Black's turn to move and find the best
move in this position
and remember if you're having trouble
you want to try and find a way to line
up your opponent's pieces so that in
this case for a skewer one of them is
more important and sits in the front and
you can attack it force it to move and
then take the weaker piece behind yeah
what's your idea
you sacrifice your roof on e4
cakes you play Bishop to C6
during
the
the queen precisely
um and Charles J once again in the chat
well founded as well Rook takes E4
sacking The Rook for the bishop with the
idea that after Queen takes now Bishop
comes to C6 and skewers the queen and
the Rook the queen has to get out of the
way wherever she goes we will take the
Rook really well found NTU is well told
in the chat
all right this is actually not from a
game or maybe it is but not that I know
of but um there's a really cool feature
if you go to leeches.com or you can
actually practice some of these and I
found this example on uh leeches's
practice for skewers so in this position
it's white to move and find the best
move
anyone have ideas how can white get an
advantage even though this position
black is up a pawn white has a way to
gain a quite decisive Advantage here
all right a few people in the chat are
suggesting some really good ideas Ted
Bradley Joe Costa
and toll uh close yeah so the idea in
this position if you're having a little
trouble seeing it is actually really
simple some of the other ones we've been
using some forcing moves you know checks
and captures to manipulate our
opponent's pieces to where we want them
to go in this case Black's pieces
already have a bit of a problem this
queen is in front of this rook and if we
simply play Rook to D2
now black is in a lot of trouble
um
the best move given by the computer is
just to take this Rook even though the
bishop will then take back so this looks
fairly comfortable for whites
because if you move the queen anywhere
I don't know if they take the spawn now
you run into a back rank issue
perhaps you can move the queen a little
better maybe to help support that back
rank but even still you will be losing
some material
so it doesn't have to be that you force
it sometimes your opponent can just put
pieces in the same row and we can find
ways to abuse them because the more
important one is in front
all right now these examples are going
to get a little bit harder I think so
far we've been doing kind of easy mode
these ones are a little tougher so if
you're having trouble with any of them
that is okay
um so this was from a game between salav
and torrentev in 1982
and the way this game went so white uh I
don't remember where this came from but
it just came to E7
attacking the queen
black pulled the queen out of the way
Pawn to D7 hoping to maybe play Rook E8
in the future or do something else to
cause some problems here for black and
so black plays Rook T8 just getting in
front of the pawn and hoping to keep it
at Bay for a while
but in this position white found a
really nice way to win the game quite
simply so see if you can find the best
move here for white
all right Charles J in the chat has a
really nice idea
um but I'll give people a second to keep
looking
Markovich 199 uh let's see yeah yep you
have the same idea
and the problem here for black is that
this bishop
and this queen and king the way they're
defending it actually allows for a
really nice tactic Rook takes G7 in this
position black resigned because you can
take the piece back with either one and
there's a problem
if the queen takes what how does white
continue here
um
precisely the queen needed to defend
this Rook so the queen cannot take but
what happens if King takes
uh not Rook but Bishop yes Bishop H6
yeah you're good you're good I know what
you meant Bishop H6 check skewering the
king and the Queen the king will have to
move out of the way
and we pick up the queen
really really nice okay this next one is
from 2002 it was Yuri Shulman versus
Alan Savage
and in this position
uh black played
Rook to E3 a really fascinating move
um attacking the queen and allowing
Bishop takes E3
but there is a slight problem with
Bishop takes C3 if we take here then
black can continue Queen takes F3 and
either get Perpetual check by taking
maybe Swinging The Rook over and even
getting the Knight involved and this can
get very dangerous for White's King
um or yeah it's either Perpetual or a
Checkmate so you cannot take this Rook
but white found another idea that allows
light to turn the tables in this
position so this is another harder one
it might take you a little bit of time
and hello to I'm going to mispronounce
your name Juan
uh Nguyen in the chat welcome sorry if I
mispronounced that
always happy to have you we're trying to
find
the best way to win this game and it's
going to involve a skewer in some way or
another
so whenever you're looking at a position
I always recommend using your forcing
moves you know checks and captures
because those are going to be the
quickest you can calculate and see
whether it works or not and you can move
on to something else
but keeping your Tactical vision in mind
how we can line pieces up see what you
can come up with here for white
someone told here suggesting the idea
Queen to C4
okay interesting so I guess the idea is
sort of the pin this Knight and put a
lot of pressure on this file
that certainly looks like a reasonable
move although there is something a
little better
Queen to F5 also suggested with check or
queen to A6 with check
both interesting we really need to
calculate out a few moves and see what's
going on with this position
Rook C7 suggested as well
Bishop takes E3 suggested
so if Bishop E3 Ted uh then black
doesn't actually play D takes E3 they
play Queen takes F3 and we our King is
pretty exposed yeah no worries no
worries
all right so I think Charles
pretty much has it in the chat but I'm
going to give you all here in the
audience in person the first move Queen
A6
uh forcing the king into a difficult
decision uh what happens if the king is
going to come over here to B8
how do you think we might continue that
I think
okay and then
so it's not Checkmate because they can
block with the Knight
so
yeah it's going to get a little
complicated because we also have to
worry about F3 hanging
um but I'm sure there is some
checkmating attack here uh
ah I see so Rook B5 and then we're
actually going to sacrifice The Rook in
order to maintain check the King has no
move so you have to take it and we can
probably take here this Rook will be
involved and this king is going to be in
a lot of danger now without anything to
guard it you know maybe something simply
like this
we take the Rook if you go that way if
you go well you can't go the other way
so you have to block and then we still
take
so that's what happens if the King goes
in this direction so and that we can
just intuitively see that looks really
dangerous
so black played the kind of natural move
King to D7 trying to run away in this
direction and hide but this exposes you
to another issue
how can white continue here
to find a winning attack
not a check meeting but a winning yeah
okay night takes
okay take again King takes
really really good yeah so all the way
back in this position
um
Savage calculated correctly the white
cannot take the Rook but he missed that
after Queen A6 there is now threats of a
skewer but because of where this queen
and king are lined
sacking The Rook second Rook
to win the Queen the king moves
somewhere anywhere
let me pick up the queen this Rook is in
danger and white went on to win this
game
all right here's another one with
unzeker in this case he has the black
pieces it says Stoltz versus zoom's
occur in 1952. and in this position
yes in this position this is another
harder one it is black to move black is
going in this direction so we're
promoting this way
and see if you can find the best idea
for black
again this is not an easy one but it is
a really really valuable puzzle
and if you're not sure but see some of
the ideas also feel free to kind of
comment or ask about them
um
yeah so Charles again in the chat really
uh doing quite well noticing that this
queen and king are in the same line
is there a way we can exploit that uh
fertessert also finding it
let me ask what happens if we just play
Queen two G4 here this looks like a
skewer right we're gonna skewer the king
and queen
does this work
what do we think is this the winning
idea for black
or is there a problem with this
yeah go ahead
uh well if the King goes to E4 then we
would just take the queen yes D4 exactly
the king can move somewhere to defend uh
D4 looks the best
um or so I'm sorry D5
D5
um but yeah so the king can move to
defend the queen so how can we make it
so there's a little bit more space
between the king and the queen well as a
few people in the chat uh yes I know
you've already you've already seen it um
but the idea here is actually really
beautiful Rook B4 first this is a pin so
now the queen can't move
uh I mean she can move over here but
there's no way to save her from being
taken by The Rook except
to take the work yourself and now the
king and queen are too far apart now
Queen to G4 check skewers this is a yeah
really kind of putting some of the the
tactics we're looking at together
combinations they do get harder but if
you can see some of the ideas right we
know this is a potential skewer and we
just have to figure out how can we
separate the queen from the king so this
was a really nice find by uh oonzeker in
52.
all right uh next one here is from 2000
or 2001 I'm not entirely sure but um
Roland uh berzinch versus Yosef pribble
and in this position it is white to move
this is another harder one and it's
going to involve some forcing moves
so some checks captures but moves that
force your opponent to go in a very
specific way in order for you to find
the best idea let's see Ted Bradley
asking what is the tactic called where
you move a piece by forcing it to
capture
um so there's two tactics there's
undermining and deflection and both of
them involve
either taking a piece or forcing it to
move somewhere you want I get them
confused a little bit I'd have to check
on my notes but it's one of those two
where you're going to force a piece to
capture
and a few people in the chat finding the
right idea so the thing that's really
cool about this position
is
that this queen is actually undefended
one of the last lessons we did here with
beginner breakdown talked about
unprotected pieces and the rule I gave
was if you can find an unprotected piece
either two unprotected pieces on your
opponent's side of the board or one
unprotected piece and an exposed King
there's usually a tactical opportunity
to win material and that's going to be
true in this position because this queen
is unprotected we're going to find a way
to force it into a skewer
and yeah so a few people have the right
idea the first move I'll show is Queen
to h8 check sacrificing the queen
because now Rook takes h8 the King has
to move
only one move and now Rook to H7 picking
up the queen skewering forcing the king
to move once again
and we eat up the queen so we sacrificed
Our Queen but we won this queen and we
won this bishop so winning more than we
give up
all right here's uh another one I'm
going to show this one is actually one
of the other Lee chess puzzles and it's
maybe the most Savage thing I've seen in
a while on the chessboard so
if you want to try and find this one uh
give it a look this is a really really
beautiful uh example that they picked so
kudos to the leeches developers website
organizers who found this tactic and
used this as an example
um
but this one is actually
it's not too hard to find the right move
but it's just beautiful when you see how
it all works together so how can we try
and generate a skewer here does anyone
have any ideas
it is white to move if I didn't say that
okay the Smasher has a suggestion uh the
Smasher online I like the name maybe
Smash Bros
Rook 2 A8 attacking the queen with the
idea that what happens if the queen
takes the Rook
what would we do in this position
yeah uh yeah Bishop to F3 skewering the
king and the Queen
so we know if we play Rook A8
that now our Rook is actually protected
you can't take it and this is where this
one gets so fun
because now that you know you can't take
this Rook you want to look at every
other line
so this is where some of the kind of
visualization and calculation comes in
play if we play this move where else can
this queen go to try and hide it can't
stay on this file so where else can the
queen go
the white diagram uh yeah anywhere on
this diagonal and it can also go here so
we have to look at every one of those
squares
and here's where it gets fun
so this looks like an option you can't
go to F7 because the bishop covers that
so we'll skip it E6
D5 oh you can't go to D5 because of the
Rook so that doesn't work
uh C4
or A2 you can't go to B3 because of the
pawn so we're looking at really four
different moves with the queen queen to
H7 Queen to E6 Queen to C4 and queen to
A2 let's take them one at a time
what happens if the queen goes to H7
how do we continue here
uh yes Bishop G6
because now our Rook covers all of these
squares so the queen can only capture
the bishop it's the only safe move and
now
yeah what was your idea
yeah Rook A6 skewering the king and the
queen so this is our first skewer well
found
okay so you can't play Queen to H7 but
we can't play Queen here so what if
Queen just goes to E6 right away
yeah Rook A6 anyway this is what black
was trying to avoid and even though the
king can move to defend the queen
um this is not really
a problem because we're happy to trade
The Rook for the Queen the only time
them moving to defend really matters is
if we're using the same like a piece of
the same worth
so if we're using a queen to skew or
another queen
okay so that doesn't work
um oh I said we couldn't go to D5 but I
was wrong we can go to D5 because now
the rook's not here haha
this isn't safe either though because
now we have a pin
okay okay Black's getting a little
nervous now but what about Queen 2c4
surely this must be safe
another skewer
okay what about Queen to A2 all the way
over hiding on the edge surely this move
is okay
for
okay Rook takes A4
what if I go back
we start the sequence over with Rook to
A8 but now you can't play Queen to A2
because there were kids that score now
and the queen is just totally trapped
so a really beautiful position where
Rook to eight the best move is actually
for black to just take because nowhere
else the queen is safe and at least this
way you get a rook
a really brutal position where the queen
is trapped even though it can go all the
way across the board not something I see
every day so that was a fun one I wanted
to share with you
okay we're going to look at three more
of these and then I want to show you uh
one final game
this position was reached in 1986
between Kasparov and uh to Tai in the
Dubai Olympiad in this position it is uh
let's see
I believe Black's turn to move and black
decided to
be a little bit greedy
and take this Pawn on A3 black is now up
a pawn which can be the difference
between winning and losing in a grand
master game
but unfortunately black did not
calculate far enough and white has a way
to win how did Kasparov go on to win
this game
see if you can find the best move for
white
yeah what's your idea
okay so we are forking the king and pawn
so we can win a pawn back I mean we
could also maybe win this Pawn here but
okay so Queen H6 uh where's the king
gonna go
um
no our night covers this Square so it
can't go here or here which means the
pawn will fall
but where is the king gonna go because
we can actually do better than just
winning a pawn
they go back to
at a or yes then we Checkmate them on
action and if they go back to
if they go into AJ's I can
then is it
there's an items yes so so far
everything is perfect Queen H6 if the
King goes in this direction we have
forced mate because if you go here we
have Queen to F7 Checkmate and if you go
over here our Queen covers everything
and Knight to F7 is Checkmate so either
way one of our pieces goes to F7 with a
square okay but that's the easy part
what if they don't give us that nice
little Checkmate and they play instead
King to E7
and I see a lot of people in the chat
with the right idea but
so kudos to all of you
what do we think here
after King E7 how can we continue
keeping skewers in mind notice where
that King is
Queen where I'm sorry
uh yeah G7 check okay
uh and yeah a slightly complex position
again we have to ask ourselves where can
the king go in this case it's only got
two options it can either take the
Knight or go to d8
if it goes to d8 then
um the same problem is going to happen
but let's start with saying they just
take the Knight
which is what happens in the game
actually
yeah here queen of Fate we've lured the
king onto the square and now they're in
trouble because we have that skewer a
little harder if black goes to d8
but we can do the same idea Queen to f8
lining Our Queen up this is not going to
be a skewer sadly but it does work out
the same way in this position yeah 98
um presumably also Knight B5 works
either way we are going to call a
discover check
and win the queen
so noticing how we can line up our
pieces with our opponents is really
useful especially for skewers okay a few
minutes yet
I'm going to skip the next two puzzles
because I well here let me show this one
I'll show this Kappa Blanca puzzle
because it's quite beautiful
if you are at home and want to take a
second to pause feel free
this is a really fun one I highly
encourage it but uh capablanca it's just
hard to beat a capablanca puzzle in this
position
he plays to invade this territory he
sees a few things going on sees this
Rook especially he sacrifices his Rook
Pawn takes Bishop takes and black
chooses not to take with the Knight
because then we will take back with the
rook and you actually cannot stop Rook
to h8 we will just play Rook to h8
almost guaranteed next move or very soon
thereafter and the king is almost
checkmated and we are certainly winning
a lot of material
so King to E7 but now Queen to G7
skewering the king in The Rook
King goes to E8 and instead of taking he
plays Queen takes G8
came to D7
Queen to H7 check again skewing the king
in The Rook
but this time it allows Queen to E7 why
does he do this because now Bishop to f8
a double skewer now he's skewering the
queen and the Rook
and after Queen takes H7
the original skewer returns
and white is winning a really beautiful
puzzle I just wanted to share that one
with you
it doesn't matter that
black gets this bishop because White's
Bishop is more than enough with the
their Rook stopping the king from ever
doing anything and Black's work is
actually really terrible on D6
but now I want to show you at the
beginning of this lecture I showed you a
game called the skewer lure which didn't
actually use a skewer used a pin so this
game I'm going to call the true skewer
lure this was in 1860 between Smith and
Derrickson and it's a really fun one
we're going to look at Black's
perspective here to finish it out so E4
E5 Bishop C4 Bishop's opening but we're
going to transpose into the Italian
which we saw before
castles Bishop C5 Pawn to D3 D6
Bishop G5 pinning the Knight to the
queen and Bishop G4 doing the same and
now H3 and black plays a really
interesting move objectively it's
probably not the best but this was the
1860s a more Romantic Era where
sacrifices were a little more common
H5
and this is kind of a sort of variance
on like the hook trap the idea is black
is actually quite happy for white to
take this bishop which is what they do
because
it opens up this Rook to help attack the
king
and using our Knight our Bishop our pawn
and the queen black is going to try and
deliver a mating attack in exchange for
the material
white plays Knight to H2
Pawn to G3 and notice that the F Pawn is
pinned so you cannot take it
so Knight Returns to F3
and in this position black plays an
absolutely stunning move
that retains that actually gets a
significant Advantage I think there's
two moves here that are acceptable but
one of them is like plus five or plus
six the other one's only plus one or two
so take a second if you want and see if
you can find the absolutely stunning
move in this position
Knight takes E4 is a really good guess
this is kind of a variant of like the
legals mate where you kind of do this
sacrifice allow the bishop to take the
queen and follow it up with like some
kind of checkmating attack I think we
just are going to run out of Firepower
because they can you know sack a lot of
material in order to make up for the
fact that they've won a queen and I
think black just barely survives but
you're really close because the actual
move is Knight to G4
uh doing something very similar but also
controlling H2 which we will see does
become somewhat relevant
white continues by taking the queen I
mean if you can take a queen usually
it's a good idea unfortunately now
Bishop takes F2
Rook takes G takes F2
King F1 and we have a skewer Rook to H1
skewering the king and queen okay King
E2 Rook D1 and now wait a minute we did
manage to skewer but we also had to give
up our Queen to do it so surely white is
going to be okay
in this position though instead of
taking the Rook uh-huh instead of taking
the Rook white played Knight F to D2
because if you take the Rook
we promote and we get our Queen back so
that's no good so Knight F to D2
stopping uh or I'm sorry Knight B to D2
would have been much better uh Knight F
to D2 is the move played but he didn't
want to play this because then you hang
this Rook as well
so this Knight now comes to guard the
promotion square and unfortunately now
Knight to D4
King takes Rook
Knight to E3 only move King to C1 and
the Pony Express walking all the way to
C1 this King has no squares and even
though we didn't get to promote this
Pawn we didn't need to
um so I'm going to call that game the
true skewer lure tricking black into or
sorry tricking white into giving up
their Queen and then following up with
this really beautiful checkmate
so that is all the time we have tonight
folks but thank you so much for joining
I hope you learned a little bit about
skewers and how to apply them in your
games
um please feel free to stick around as I
believe we have our Grandmaster class
right afterwards so please enjoy that
and hope to see you again soon
[Music]